Okay, there's a lot of math and.
>> Mm-hm.
>> There's a lot of research behind
those numbers but the numbers are still the
numbers and I imagine, you know, it has sort of an anxiety effect on, on an
individual. Or did you feel anxious or worried and what did you end up doing?
Did you, did you, did it change anything for you and did you take an action?
>> Well, I was very anxious and I called my doctor,
he was away. I called another doctor and he was away. And I
called a friend who works at one of those local hospitals and I said this is the
situation, what do you recommend I do? And she gave me the name of a doctor,
and it was confirmed, by the time I had that information it was confirmed by
the doctor who had returned. So I went to see a breast oncologist
and, at a very large medical center
and at the same time she scheduled me to see a genetic
counselor. which is recommended, when you, when you get
this information it's recommended that you speak to someone and see
someone who understands the genetics so I did see this person in
the physician and the generic counselor on the same day and she was
gave me a very thorough exam and a very thorough explanation there was no rush.
And I was advised, to consider, strongly
having my ovaries removed. And to have twice a year breast exam,
and a one time a year breast MRI,
and a breast mammogram. And I followed up, I've already followed up
two times. I see her twice a year, and I've had the MRI and breast exam twice.
>> Wow, you took a lot of action.
>> I did.
>> And this was all based on the advice and the the
I should say the, the medical advice of a genetic counselor and your clinician?
>> Right. And the genetic council took a history of
everyone in the family, mother's, mother's, father's,
grandfather's. And it was interesting
to, to find out my grand, my maternal grandmother
died when my mother was five. So we're talking about the 1920s and I was always
told my grandmother died of stomach cancer and the genetic counts that brought
up the possibility that she had had ovarian cancer, of course we wouldn't know,
this was the 1920s. And that was what we, would be heard, that she died
of stomach cancer but it could have been ovarian cancer.
>> In this process, was it, was it just a personal decision for you or did you
include family members in, in discussing it and
trying to figure out what to do as well?
>> Well, I'll be married 50 years in.
>> Contraulations.
>> 2014. I'm very close with my husband, and he and
I discussed this, and it just seemed like it was the right thing to do. Of
course, I read a lot, and I had family
members who had breast cancer, and ovarian cancer,
and none of them were BRCA2 or any BRCA
for that matter. So, it wasn't as if I knew anybody that
had this, was in this situation.
>> if you had any advice to tell somebody who
just found out they have a BRCA 1 or BRCA 2
mutation, is there anything you think it's important for them to
know or any particular advice or message you would give them?
>> Well, if someone does inquire and finds out.
I certainly think they should get genetic counselling. And see
a physician who is a specialist, in breast
oncology. Who is aware of the latest and greatest
research. we're fortunate to live in an area where
there are wonderful hospitals and research centers. And so I strongly
advise people to take action and
do what's best for them. I know age is a
factor. If you find out you're in your 20s or 30s
and you haven't started a family or had children yet, what's
recommended might be entirely different than what was recommended for me.
>> Great. Carol, thank you so much for being here.
>> Thank you for exploring this topic.